شقوا فروه الراس ازاله قطعه من الجمجمه
بحجم العمله المعدنيه ثم روبوت يدخل
اقطابا كهربائيه في دماغ بشري هذا ليس
خيالا علميا بل حقيقه امن بها ايلون ماسك
والان سيشرع في تطبيقها بعد اعلان شركته
نيورالينك الحصول على موافقه اداره الغذاء
والدواء الامريكيه لاجراء اولى الاختبارات
السريريه لزرع شرائح ذكيه في ادمغه البشر
نحن حارسنا على ان يعمل بشكل جيد قبل وضع
الجهاز في ادمغه البشر
البدانه والتوحد والاكتئاب والفصام والعمى
جميعها حالات يرى ماسك ان تقنيته ستساهم
في علاجها ورغم تصريحاته بانه مستعد لزرع
هذه التقنيه في اطفاله الى ان هناك مخاوف
كثيره لدى الخبراء حول امكانيه انتقال
اسلاك الزرع داخل الدماغ وصعوبه استخراج
جهاز بامان دون اتلاف الانسجه واعتماد
التقنيه على بطاريه ليثيوم
التخوفات تتزامن مع اتهامات لشركته بتسبب
تجاربها بقتل 1500 حيوان منذ عام 2018
بينها خنازير وقرده
مؤخرا نجح علماء في سويسرا من دفع مشلول
لعشر سنوات على المشي عبر احدى تقنيات
الذكاء الاصطناعي بالوصل بين دماغه وحبله
الشوكي عبر لوحه رقميه تعتمد تقنيه بي سي
اي التي تحول الافكار الى حركات
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات